[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
a jury could soon deliver a verdict in
the sarah lawrence college cold case the
defense has rested and larry ray will
not be testifying so this case is
spiraling toward a conclusion plus two
high-profile jury selections begin in
florida what you need to know about the
coming trials of anthony tote and
nicholas cruz plus the state calls its
final witness in the olympian attempted
murder trial i will never ever forget
that moment in time but first officials
search for more answers following a
deadly mass shooting in sacramento
california law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer six people
are killed and 12 more injured following
a mass shooting in sacramento california
on monday police announced a 26-year-old
man was arrested in connection to the
deadly shooting spree
on monday police announced deandre
martin was taken into custody he was
charged with assault with a firearm and
being a prohibited person in possession
of a firearm officials also say swat
members and detectives served warrants
following the deadly shooting the
shooting happened early sunday morning
just blocks from the state capitol
building officials say a fight broke out
near a popular bar and club area after
that shots rang out three men and three
women were killed at least 12 others
were injured in all more than a hundred
shots were fired and caught on video
officials also noted a stolen handgun
was recovered from the scene all this
comes just hours after one person was
killed and 11 more injured at an outdoor
concert in dallas texas texas
investigators are working to determine
the number of suspects in that case and
have not made any arrests in connection
to the deadly
shooting joining us today is legal
analyst kirk nermey and co-host terry
austin as we discuss these latest mass
shootings kirk from the head coach of
the golden state warriors to the head of
the state president joe biden many have
commented on this tragedy saying that
more than thoughts and prayers are
needed what do you think can help curb
gun violence like these we're seeing
yeah certainly brian you know we've seen
that thoughts and prayers are certainly
not a prevention strategy understandable
but they're not preventing these
shootings that happen over and over
again what really needs to happen is we
need to get serious about
access and mental health because we see
in a case like this the man one of the
men arrested in this shooting was a
prohibited possessor meaning it was not
lawful to him to own a weapon how did he
get that what loss can change to prevent
a person like that from getting that
getting access to a gun and then when we
move forward we see these other mass
shootings like mr cruz or mr crumbly and
these school shootings we see mental
health issues come to the forefront why
haven't we done more in terms of the
mental health aspects of the shooting to
try to prevent it to get those people
helped before they act out those are the
kind of strategies that are really going
to prevent shootings like this one and
ones we've seen in schools recently
absolutely what investigative steps do
you think uh can be taken in order to
find those responsible for these two
mass shootings both in sacramento and
dallas
well we know that the authorities are
going to do every single thing that they
can to get these people prosecuted i
agree with kirk though we can't do too
much we have to do much more than we've
done already but this particular case
they're going to look at where that
fight broke out they're going to try to
identify every single witness who was
there they're going to talk to those
people if you saw something then you
should say something and i think most
importantly they're going to look at any
videos that might have been around and
get those clips to determine who was
there and who was doing all of the
shooting
well of course give you updates on both
of these deadly shootings as more news
comes in uh through our days continue
on update now on the so-called house of
horrors as the california foster family
is accused of abusing the turpin family
children a california foster mother
father and daughter are all charged with
sexually and physically abusing nine
children in all including five of the
turpin children the turpin family made
headlines in 2018 when they were rescued
from their biological parents home at
the time 17 year old jordan turpin
escaped from her house and called 9-1-1
reporting that her parents dad and
louise turpin locked her away along with
her 12 siblings later reports detailed
torture malnourishment and several
children being chained to their beds in
2019 both parents pled guilty to 14
felony counts including cruelty to a
dependent adult torture and false
imprisonment a few months after the
turpin children were rescued they were
placed in a california foster home where
more abuse is said to have continued the
turpin children's foster parents now
face several charges including false
imprisonment and child cruelty
still ahead on law and crime daily two
high-profile jury selections are now
underway in the sunshine state but first
the state rests its case in the olympian
attempted murder trial hear from the
state's final witness
[Music]
welcome back the state reads his case in
the olympian attempted murder trial the
state's final witness the attorney for
lauren kanarak who was on the phone with
his client as she was shot twice in the
chest
former olympian michael barisson faces
two counts of attempted murder dating
back to the 2019 shooting of lauren
canorack and shots fired at her
boyfriend robert goodwin at the time
goodwin and canara act were dating and
lived together on baristan's property
defense attorneys say baris owned feared
for his life at the time of the shooting
and suffered from mental health issues
even sleeping in a stable leading up to
the incident ahead of the shooting
barristone was training canarak in
dressage riding as she lived on his
property in the days leading up to the
shooting a string of 911 calls were made
by both parties barris barristones
saying he was trying to evict canarack
and can iraq saying she was being
harassed on monday jurors heard from
canarax attorney edward david who heard
the shooting over the phone
i heard her say oh my god there's
barisone
he's got a gun or
something like that and then i heard
what i thought were gunshots
and i said lauren lauren lauren are you
okay
um
he sh i i believe she said something
like he shot me in the heart or the
chest
and then i heard the phone drop
and
i was obviously in shock the fact that i
heard gunshots is immutable
i heard gunshots the fact that lauren
said i've been shot in the chest is
immutable i heard that and it happened
no amount of trauma is going to change
that
there are things that
which you reminded me of there were
other things that that happened
that i now recollect
but i will never ever forget
that moment in time
back to break down the latest in the
michael barrus own case as the
prosecution rests is legal analyst kirk
nermey and terry austin terry how do you
think the defense started their case was
this the right or wrong witness to start
with
well they started out with the private
investigator i think that was the right
witness they're trying to show two
things one that it was self-defense two
that he was very distraught and why was
he distraught because we know that
lauren and robert goodman were
definitely trying to harass him and
bully him and the private investigator
actually was looking into their
background sadly though that was not
really allowed into court and they did
not talk about that report so we'll see
whether or not the jury picks up on that
the rest of the defense i think was very
good as far as showing that he was
distraught and that they made complaints
against him and it really hurt his
well-being now kirk let's go a little
bit back in terms of before the defense
put on witnesses the defense as they
always do and should ask for dismissal
after the prosecution rested did the
judge do the right thing in saying this
case should go to the jury
yeah he did because when we think about
it brian you know the judge is not there
to assess the credibility of the
witnesses that's the job of the jury in
a question like this when a question
like this is put before the judge his or
her job is to decide whether the state
has advanced enough evidence to secure
conviction and really the
testimony of both us alleged victims is
enough to get to do that and if we keep
in mind too the defenses here are
affirmative defenses the defense hasn't
really done anything to contradict those
facts they're just saying that they
happened but they were in self-defense
or due to insanity so ultimately it's
pretty clear that the state has met
their burden at least to advance the
case to the jury so the judge made the
right call in this situation yeah it's
at least enough for any competent jury
to consider the facts and weigh them
based on the charges and like you said
those affirmative defenses are something
they're going to be weighing as well
coming up on law and crime daily both
sides rest in the sarah lawrence college
sex cult federal trial plus we're taking
a closer look at jury selection in two
high-profile florida cases what to
expect in the trials of nicholas cruz
and anthony tobin
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily jury
selection begins for the highly
anticipated sentencing phase of parkland
school shooter nicholas cruz a jury will
soon decide whether the 23 year old
should be sentenced to the minimum of
life in prison or receive the death
penalty cruz pled guilty in october of
last year for the deadly marjory
stoneman douglas high school shooting
that's where in february of 2018 crews
opened fire killing 17 people and
injuring 17 more 12 jurors and eight
alternates will be chosen from a pool of
more than 1500 people cruz will only
receive the death penalty if the juror
unanimously agrees that aggravating
factors like the cruelty and planning of
the act outweigh mitigating factors such
as mental illness or the death of his
parents if one juror disagrees cruz will
not receive the death penalty last week
attorneys from both sides indicated the
sentencing phase could stretch from four
to six months law and crime daily is set
to bring you live coverage when the
penalty phase begins
also in florida jury selection begins in
the case of anthony tope a man accused
of murdering his wife three young
children and family dog not far from
disney world federal authorities found
toad's wife two sons daughter and the
family dog dead in their celebration
florida home in early 2020. officials
were there to arrest the physical
therapist on unrelated insurance fraud
charges when the bodies were discovered
in a jailhouse letter to his father tote
claimed his wife was to blame for the
killings when tote was arrested he said
he had taken benadryl in an attempt to
commit suicide the judge previously
ruled to allow one confession from tote
but exclude another after detectives
failed to fully inform him of his
miranda rights last week a judge ruled
toad's mental health issues could not be
included in the defense's case stay with
law and crime network for galvalgal
coverage of the case live coverage
begins with opening statements
legal analyst kirk nermey and co-host
terry austin join us again as we tackle
jury selection in two major florida
cases terry let's start with toad this
case has changing stories a confession
then part of the confession gets thrown
out and tote now says his wife did it so
how do you nail down a defense when your
client can't be clear so what happened
you know this is going to be a very
difficult defense for this defendant
because his
story changes and i think what we're
going to have to see from the attorney
they're going to have to pick a theory
they're going to have to stick with that
theory and the theory is what he wrote
to his father in that letter from prison
and they're going to have to argue that
when he's talking to his father he's
telling the truth and he's saying look
the wife did it she killed her kids she
killed herself it wasn't me i had
nothing to do with it and they're going
to have to say that this confession was
something that was not a real confession
that it was forced upon him and he was
just upset at the time and he was taking
blame for it so they're going to have to
explain that away it's going to be very
hard because it looks like all of the
evidence right now points directly to
him and it doesn't seem as though there
is any evidence as far as suicide is
concerned yeah and what's even more
difficult a lot of the points that
you're making terry sound like points
that can only come from him so maybe
he's got to take the stand i don't know
we'll see when it comes up kirk let's
switch now to cruz short of just being
against the death penalty do you think
there's a juror who says cruz doesn't
deserve the death penalty and how much
weight do you think a jury should give
to the fact that he admitted his guilt
well ultimately brian i think the
difficulty there's a difficulty in
finding jurors like that that's why we
see that they pulled 1500 people but in
order to be lawful a juror has to have
be open to both penalties has to be
opened to death and has to be open to
life so we're going to see the jurors
use uh jurors to be given questionnaires
in order to assess that and brian i've
selected juries in death penalty cases
high profile ones and ultimately it's
different for those jurors when they're
in the courtroom versus when they're
talking about the death penalty with
their friends so it takes on a whole new
light and they're going to be asked can
they give consideration to the
mitigating factors put forward any of
them and they're going to have to be
able to say yes in order to be seated as
a jury so it's going to be a long
process it's going to be a tough process
but i think ultimately they're going to
find the 20 or so jurors they need it's
just going to take a while absolutely
and we'll be there as it takes a while
as two trials begin a third is nearing
the finish line as closing arguments are
set to be presented in the trial of
ex-icu doctor william hussell both sides
rested last week in a case law and crime
network has brought you gavel to gabriel
live coverage of who cells accused of
murdering 14 patients while practicing
medicine as an icu doctor at mount
carmel st anne's hospital in columbus
ohio prosecutors say hussell gave deadly
amounts of fentanyl to multiple patients
resulting in their murders defense
attorneys countered saying hussel was
providing end-of-life care after more
than 50 prosecution witnesses and weeks
of testimony the state rested its case
last week famed defense attorney jose
baez called only one witness to the
stand both sides are expected to present
closing arguments on tuesday make sure
to watch the law on crime network for
live coverage and up to the minute
developments in the case
when we come back both sides rest in the
sarah lawrence college federal trial law
and crime network's adam classville
brings us the latest developments from
the federal courthouse in new york
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily a
federal judge rules that can guilty
conviction will stand for former
socialite gillane maxwell co-host terry
austin joins us now to explain why
maxwell will not receive a new trial
brian on friday federal judge allison
nathan ruled that maxwell does not
deserve a new trial based on alleged
jury misconduct this comes after
maxwell's defense pushed for a new trial
saying during number 50 did not act as a
fair and impartial juror in the highly
publicized trial on the jury
questionnaire filled out ahead of the
trial the juror known as scotty david
indicated he had not been sexually
assaulted but during deliberations and
post-trial interviews david revealed
that he had been sexually assaulted as a
child during questioning under oath
david told judge nathan he was
distracted and he quickly filled out the
questionnaire maxwell's defense team
argued that the admission was grounds to
vacate the jury's guilty verdict while
federal prosecutors say that david made
an honest mistake judge nathan later
determined it was quote highly
unfortunate but not deliberate that
david failed to disclose his history of
sexual assault maxwell was convicted on
multiple counts in december of last year
relating to sex trafficking and grooming
of young girls prosecutors say maxwell
helped recruit underage girls for her
companion the late financier jeffrey
epstein maxwell is scheduled to be
sentenced in june she faces up to 65
years in prison brian
also in federal court both sides rest in
the case of accused sarah lawrence sex
call leader lawrence ray this after the
defense began and ended arguing its case
with just two witnesses taking the stand
ray is facing a possible life sentence
on a 17 indictment of federal charges
including racketeering sex trafficking
and tax evasion among others the charges
all stem from alleged crimes dating back
to 2010 when ray allegedly started the
rave family a cult made off of his
daughter and her sarah lawrence college
friends throughout the prosecution's
case jurors heard from rey's alleged
victims including three siblings santos
felicia and julissa rosario and their
mother also among his alleged victims is
claudia jury who testified about
becoming a sex worker at rey's urging
she told the jury about giving him the
money she earned while engaging in sex
work on monday morning the defense
called its first witness a cell site
data expert who was called to rebut
earlier testimony about cell phone
locations of jury and ray's co-defendant
isabella pollock their second and final
witness was rey's former attorney who
the defense claims gave ray advice to
take the money from jury they say it was
restitution after ray believed drury
tried to poison him
law and crime's adam classfield has been
inside the courtroom watching the story
unfold he joins us now as the defense
presents its short case
folks i'd spoken to said this is just a
hail mary pass by the defense and let's
put it into perspective their 17 count
indictment this entire defense goes to a
couple of charges of tax evasion to go
into what the testimony was it was
downright bizarre the lawyer mr ripa had
testified that he did not preserve any
billing records he
noted that ray paid in cash on
cross-examination the prosecutors made a
point that he didn't have any kind of
outside corroboration any medical
records that drury in fact
poisoned mr ray
when asked if he had heard that rey was
accused of forcing her into prostitution
he replied absolutely not so the crux of
the defense here
is ray supposedly believing
that it was authorized on advice of
counsel
to take money from claudia drury's
prostitution
to repay
restitution for the supposed poisoning
larry ray will not be testifying so this
case is spiraling toward a conclusion
kirk ripa's testimony sounded horrible
for the defense and of course it did no
lawyer is telling their client to force
someone into sex work to pay their debts
did the witness crush this defense's
chance of a victory
well exactly brian you're right
no attorney is going to make that give
that advice and know that there was no
there's no chance of victory to crush
here brian the evidence is so strong
there's no real defense to any of this
so i think what we really have is a
long-form guilty plea this trial is not
only winding down but winding towards a
conviction that i think the jury will
reach very quickly absolutely terry
isabella pollack allegedly films some of
the damaging videos she's being tried
separately what do you think the case
against her will look like
well they're alleging that she is his
accomplice and frankly this reminds me a
lot of the jeffrey epstein delaine
maxwell case where she was his
accomplice and she apparently was there
filming all of this who knows maybe she
was actually grooming some of the
individuals who were victims here and
the evidence is so clear it is certainly
like kirk said this is something that i
think the jury is going to determine
very quickly and when the case against
pollock happens i think her verdict will
be quick as well absolutely thank you
both for joining us and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you